Agrivoltaics is
our new take on how
to transform how
we do agriculture
in the dry lands of the world.
And so it's really a
co-location of solar panels,
or renewable energy, over
an understory, if you will,
of agricultural plants.
We essentially carry around
this portable biosphere.
This way of dialing the
environmental conditions
of what plants need--
the carbon dioxide
level of the atmosphere,
the temperature, the light,
the relative
humidity-- everything
we can control inside the
biosphere at a larger scale,
we control at the smaller scale.
We could be really applying
these simple principles
to really change how we go
into the future in terms
of how we approach local
agriculture, how we approach
renewable energy.
All these things that
the next generation
finds really important.
We're here at University
of Rincon High School
and this is a satellite garden
to the agrivoltaic garden
at Biosphere 2.
And so, we've replicated
some of the conditions
and replicated some
of the plant choices.
And we're engaging with
high school students
to help with some of the
monitoring and data collection.
This is citizen science
in a different way.
This is a permanent
installation.
And so we have time
to bring scientists
in to work with us on
procedures and protocol.
And we have time to
collect data and to process
that data in a meaningful way.
And we have time to
build relationships
with those researchers,
where they come in
and these kids become
really a significant part
of the research.
Here these high school kids are
contributing to big science.
And they make the science
at Biosphere better science.